well hello there reject nation olivia's
back with me today thrilling because
we cover avatar less or better we
covered all of it on our patreon watch
alongs and reaction highlights over
there and we just finished season two of
legend of korra as well and we've had
this promise for a while
we're doing the last airbender movie now
i am kind of excited this is to see it
ever heard nothing but good things about
it you excited i was excited and then
allergies let the allergies do the job
yeah it's rough it's not like we live
together and we can't just shoot this
some other day it has to be right now
anyway guys want the full length to
watch along for this movie reaction you
could check us out on patreon become a
super sexy reject today oh we got a
whole bunch of other stuff there too if
you don't want to do that leave a like
that would mean a lot we only call the
people who subscribe to your patreon
super sexy she watches the channel also
subscribe and click that notification
bell because we want to get notified
when our reaction for some other movie
is up here and thanks to the boys at
prep for helping us edit this down
[Music]
water
earth
[Music]
i don't know what that one is
dust
the avatar was the only person born
amongst all the nations who could master
all four elements
with the spirit's guidance
the avatar kept balance in the world
cool and then a hundred years ago
he just disappeared
book one are we gonna do all of them
that must be guitar
a white girl
stop doing that stuff around me
i always get wet
grade a acting
hey hey just started
already
thrilled about this
move away from the cracks
let's see it
do not hit that sphere
[Music]
hey it's kind of cool
they really are white huh very white she
kind of looks like uh buff of the
vampire slaver's younger sister
oppa i mean that's pretty cool
he looks dead right now but i'm sure
once he actually flies yes i'll be
ecstatic
we need to get him back to the village
what is this thing
he's trying to eat me
i ran away from home
we got in a storm
we were forced under the water of the
ocean
the vfx aren't bad no they're good what
if we end up loving this movie i'm a
little worried
we're gonna love it
i mean acting is not great but
there's something wrong
no
please wait here
it feels like a 90s movie
like braveheart yeah
like steven seagal's the siege
coincidence that we break him out of the
ice light shoots in the sky and now the
fire nation is here with their machines
dev patel zuko silka
don't
how'd you pronounce it zuko zucco no no
it's saka i know but i thought
bring me
oh you're elderly
[Music]
grandma
damn they are so white
at least there's asian people in the
village
who are you
what's your name i don't need to tell
you anything
i'm taking you to my ship if you don't
come
i'll burn down this village
i'll go with you
boy everything's happening so quickly
this feels that way because they're
condensing a bunch of episodes
they were looking for someone old and
they were looking for someone with the
same markings the boy had we found that
boy he's our responsibility we should
fight what would you do if they try to
take me away
that kills them all soccer's so serious
in this movie i know
it's so cute oh that's so cool where's
your little stepped up on
what do you want with me
my nephew wants me to perform a little
test on you
iro
that's ira
okay
weird
it only takes a few moments and then
you're free to go
would you mind if i put a few things in
front of you at the table
eero
have we been saying it wrong this whole
time
no we were saying it right he's hanging
around
the fire nation doesn't wish to live by
the spirits that's why they are so
frightened by the existence of the
avatar he will begin to change hearts
and it is in the heart
that all wars are one i think it's in
the weapons
i think it's in the nuclear bombs
oh are they going to teach them how to
use all four elements
no they're running the experiments auto
inadvertently teach him
you
are my prisoner
really half-assed that scar did
it is truly an honor to be in your
presence
don't even try to escape
this is abortion
ah cool [ __ ] make a little circle ball
little air ball
[Music]
i didn't do the ball
don't move
i mean he's got a lot he's gonna fly
[Music]
thanks for bringing opera to me
the fire nation is up to something i
have to go back now we'll come with you
why
i don't understand what's happening
it's not conflicting enough for them
aung flew us to his home he told us how
he left there in a storm on up why can't
they pronounce anyone's name right
cool
aung air bended a sphere around them and
ice oh he couldn't remember anything
after that
what is happening
monkey atta's gonna try and jump out and
scare me at any moment
he's the teacher responsible for me boy
i love the relationship building we're
getting between all three of them
is it okay if you tell me your name the
monks named me ang okay guys
enough
oh my [ __ ] god it's mom you're behind
us
that does not look real
we keep them as pets weren't they
extinct a long time ago
exchange no there must be thousands of
them on this mound your friends were
monks
i know where they are right now didn't
he say that would they land it did she
does she know it's been a hundred years
what'd you guys talk about when you run
i think you're in that ice
for almost 100 years firebender started
a war
what did they talk about
is a lot darker than i was expecting it
to be
yeah
it feels like when a youtuber makes a
serious gritty version
we've gotten no character building from
any of these
[Music]
oh thank god i'm so worried i'm glad
they're able to pull him out of that
dark hole
i commend the fire lords discipline for
example it seems i need to remind prince
zuko that during his banishment he is an
enemy of the fire it's an appropriate
uncle
i was going to make a joke but decided
not to
like a child wearing a
costume one day my father will take me
back and you will bow before me
i'd be gay
look at that rubber sword
i don't know if it's called
it's so rubbery
rubbery
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god are we gonna get uh his sister
oh that'd be great
azula queen azula you mean
why is he standing like that
i think it's good to frame action scenes
in a way where you can't see a lot of
the
just keeping a really tight shot
he's like hunchback like
you know my grandma thinks because
you're an airbender that you could be
the avatar
uh he was in ice for a hundred years
are you the avatar wrong
it's tough
what is this no
stay hidden if they don't make toff
blind i'd be very upset
it's got the green up that child was
being arrested for what he was bending
tiny stones at us from behind a tree oh
she's a bender another one
katara
classic
i love how they reserved all the asian
people for just
i was gonna say or the uh the fire
nation
and they sent their machines
huge machines made of metal
there's nothing we could do those who
could not bend were allowed to live in
peace
if we were in prison
i'm pretty sure they're just doing like
five minutes of each episode i i think
that's what it is yeah if the avatar had
returned would that mean anything to you
the avatar is dead if he was here he
would protect us
well
and i'm the avatar
i ran away but i'm back i appeared to
you all
ah
is he doing that
how is he doing that is it air better
earthbending's the coolest in the show
in this movie for sure don't be afraid
it's my favorite in the show too
no air is the coolest in the show but in
this movie earth bending's the coolest
why is that one fire nation guy just
standing there waiting for his turn
look at all the fire nation guys not
doing nothing
they just gave up they literally just
left
i guess i'm fascinated because this
could have been a really cool movie done
right like they have everything here
they took away any tools related to
bending
you have the earth
why does momo sound like nosferatu
the fire nation took this scroll from a
member of your water tribe damn that's
convenient i need to tell you something
what is it um
i ran away before they trained me to be
the avatar
i don't know how to bend the other
elements but we saw you move that rock
earlier they said i could never have a
normal life that i could never have a
family they said that's a sacrifice the
avatar always has to make okay
so what what if we found you teachers
teachers to teach you bending which
element would you have to learn first
and a woman what if we found you a woman
take my sister
they're just gonna
wow
what exactly is the plot of this movie
if you're like
fast forwarding through you're like
that's just happening
they're fast forwarding through the plot
of the actual show this is fascinating
it's just like stuff happens is this
movie it really had the potential to be
something like
decent
even with its wide watch you could have
the potential to be certainties
yeah that's right sherlock shocks the
scroll we have had was proving to be
helpful
ong was practicing
but for some reason
he was having trouble with water bending
maybe because
it's moving so fast
we moved from town to town in the earth
kingdom we try to stay out of sight but
soka became concerned we were being
followed he became concerned why would
you think you were not big fella i don't
understand this
the land of oz that's exactly what that
looks like we could bring down the
northern water tribe city we could show
the world the true strength of fire
i am pleased
i'm going to say that after sex now oh
um please
my son doesn't find this person first
and he turns out to be the avatar he
would return as a hero and for all
purposes be your superior well
i suppose it's a race then what is this
the dad is kind of on his side in this
show in this movie
i'll roll with it
it's my whole experience of this so far
he spoke out of turn
to a general
in defense of some of his friends
who are going to be sacrificed in a
battle then principal was sentenced to
an agony key duel
what is that how do they pronounce
anything right
he would not fight his father then
his father mocked him and said
i should bring your sister up here to
beat you yes
yes
father burned his son
to teach him a lesson
left him a very minor scar very minor
you can't even tell looking at it
directly on right now
[Laughter]
he thinks if he goes to another
spiritual place
he can get back to the spirit world i
don't think that's a good idea
we started a rebellion try to talk about
it did you when uh ten minutes ago we're
just time jumping like every two months
every five minutes is every two months
later
what has happened it's actually started
off like this might not be so bad
like there's so much happening in this
one movie
this little kid worked out for six
months before doing this
damning super easy bailey and
inconvenience once that yapping woman
ate next to him
[Laughter]
it's been like six months for him you
know
you gotta overcome your trauma this
movie is not good it's better than
dragon ball evolution
[Laughter]
these are all the avatars
i like how reincarnations of they're all
not burnt in the same exact areas
yeah you will forgive me won't you for
what for luring you down here
okay
poverty because of your absence avatar
oh yes finally
my actions today
this is actually one of the most
believable parts of the movie is that
someone's finally like where the [ __ ]
have you been
i know
my life he doesn't even seem to be
dealing with being uh
she's like i've adjusted
you must go to the northern water tribe
if they take that city more will suffer
and die as your airbenders have
you must go now you okay
yes it's kind of boring
don't worry i'm
not going to kill you
i'm just going to hurt you really really
really bad
i think aesthetically some of this
shit's cool
already
even if we hadn't seen this show i still
think this is really rushed this feels
like non-stop but it's because it's
definitely worse because i've seen the
[ __ ] yeah but no i would still have the
same complaints i feel like so much is
happening here let's just keep skipping
time and yet we have no character
development yeah
what's going on here
i didn't know we had white guards
yeah that wig is wild
[Music]
this is very convenient for him that
that was there
he's good at the action oh kinda bored
do not kill the avatar
he will just be reborn again
why are you doing this who are you
that's a scary ass mask damn open the
gates
let them out
i feel like a bunch of people could have
gotten the drop off don't you have bows
and arrows archers
right over here they wait so many so
many people are there
so many people could have gotten a job
on it do it
whoa
why'd you wait for me to get that far i
don't understand
[Music]
[Music]
i mean that guy's really good with the
stick man he is really talented at that
it's really hard to do what he's doing
[Music]
that's your fault what is this you let
him go like [ __ ] 500 000 feet before
launching an arrow to
aha
i like how the action thinks it's cooler
than what it is yeah
but now he's really good with the stick
toward the man
probably a competitive martial artist or
something
i think we moved on to season two season
three the word that came down
is this person the soldiers are calling
the blue spirit yes
why'd they frame
the father like he's a mysterious figure
we have
did he control fire
i don't think they know what their
powers are in this movie he's gone to
seek out someone in the northern water
tribe where they have lived beyond our
reach and openly practice water bending
it's an abomination
oh it looks kind of creepy
yeah the animals have no personality
start acting like dracula
this looks cool though it looks great
this is the north though isn't aren't
they bad and much decor
it's the moon lady
my brother and the princess became
friends right away
thank you for telling us all this we
don't have time to show you
we don't have time to build really look
at the look that's all you're gonna get
they're in love now if we let too many
of them into this city their sheer
numbers could overwhelm us as many fires
in this city should be put out as
possible in the alarm sounds we want to
minimize their benefit they all look the
same there's no boomi
it's not booming
presence is our inspiration i'll do it
that's me i'll be her guard nothing will
happen to her
they're in love
oh did you have that feeling this movie
just skips over any and all character
development
just
you've you've seen that you've seen the
show right you just want us to reference
it right
[Laughter]
water teaches us
acceptance your emotions flow like water
act impulsively that's what i that's
what i picked up no rational or logical
explanations for any emotion
see you got this
your son died in that siege didn't he
yes he did
again i offer my condolences on your
nephew running to death in that terrible
accident
i've loved spending these weeks with you
weeks
[Laughter]
my grandmother will
ask you a lot of questions why is your
hair white young lady you look very odd
i would say to you grandmother my hair
is white because when i was born i was
not awake my mother and father could not
get me to make a sound or move i wasn't
actually asking i was making a joke
dipped me into the sacred waters my
parents said that
my hair turned white then and
life put into me that's faster
you didn't tell me that
she just did you didn't ask me only your
grandmother did
talk to me about your grandma
i'm rooting for that
zhao has no sacredness
are you sure you want to be here
i don't want to be
i here not be allowed to live in peace
until i bring the avatar to my father
is that not clear to you
they don't think you're dead go start a
new life god dude this cast has no
chemistry
it's it's pretty rough they and like
none of them feel like at all from there
what do you mean animated feels like
what
none of them feel all for their animated
counterparts
and they all just feel like
flat one-note versions of
something i don't even know what they
are
oh is this where they fall in love
oh these two especially have no cameras
oh my god
the writing doesn't even try don't know
you wouldn't even know that
they end up together in the show because
this is
so dull
there's no life behind the story some of
these visual effects are phenomenal
though no i agree but this is so good
fire nation is here
cora is a more interesting character
than all
that says something maybe jesus sure
i actually think this will make me
appreciate it they're proud to have
legend of korra or out the window now
congratulations congratulations
[Music]
i'm trying not to keep comparing it to
the show but it's just as bad if you
don't compare to the
it's worse to be compared but
man
[Music]
actually
oh my god he found superman's later i
have to talk to the dragon spirit he can
help me defeat the fire nation
okay
is there a spiritual place where i can
meditate you've been there for weeks
[Laughter]
and you're just
asking where you're gonna meditate
what the hell some of the great monks
can meditate
for four days
we don't have that kind of time i should
have asked about this couple weeks ago
uh i love this moment in the show
remember this is my one of my favorite
episodes
i'll take you
and her hair is not white it's clearly a
little bit pink and lavender there but
okay whatever
he's trying to meditate
i love you
fire lord son
you took him from our village
that was
like two years ago this time
won't you cool down
my name is katara
and i'm the only water bender left in
the southern water what
why are you giving him this information
seemed like you were confessing
something to him like hey i'm trying to
work with you
that was pretty believable considering
we've not seen her
progress at all hey we haven't seen
anyone
[Laughter]
true
the water vendors get power from the
moon they will get stronger as the day
comes to an end
general hero i've been keeping a secret
i would pronounce your name wrong hotel
i found a scroll
which tells the location of the ocean
and moon spirits
to meet a spirit why
why are they telling
everything to each other
they've successfully invaded
they had no measures to prevent
no issues at all actually
did they say if they got through the
city walls well there you go what
is my makeup still into it zuko's here
in the city
he took hong again
she delivers all and then i heard him
say
he couldn't leave with that
i think we can convince him to be
friends you are angry
you must let this go
as the avatar you are not meant to hurt
others
yeah i didn't pick up on any of that i
didn't realize he was struggling
with this emotion because
i haven't seen any of it so go
do this now
[Music]
this is like a b movie with a great
production
boy zuko is so dumb in this in this
movie
holy toledo
[Laughter]
calm down
you'll find it
release the extended cut to stop a
character moment
water unleashed
[Applause]
[Music]
are you okay dude this soccer guy's just
coasting through scene no job at all
nothing
he's got a creepy ass face set up
boy when was this made this
not good
see where they're going i'll go join the
fight
okay
do more of your practice form
choreography we are now the gods
it has begun
has he turned evil
it's a pretty cool shot looks like his
hand's on fire you can give your life
back for the spirits
don't listen to him
nothing i don't understand how this
movie doesn't get better
so it gets worse
there are reasons
we have to find those reasons
if you haven't seen avatar you're like
who the [ __ ] is this
why is he friends with them now
how can you understand you don't know
what will happen i believe that you know
the voice will leave my body and return
to the moon spirit oh not this character
i
love so much
my people are dying sokka
those who are in charge of others have a
responsibility
it's time we show the fire nation that
we believe in our beliefs as much as
they believe can we say our vows like
this
yeah no emotion just stoned me towards
my mother i'll miss you
more than you know
she's actually the best child actor out
of them
but he is not good
oh man
they're like get those look at them
[Music]
that's why she had the white hair
they told us that
so they're just showing us in this
moment man sako was my favorite
character
[Music]
so the span of like
15 minutes they killed the fish
the moon was
turned red
she died moon's back
aang had a mid-life crisis about killing
people
somehow
he cares about the spirits or something
you know
who are these for it's for randos i have
no idea who they are
oh my god they should have murdered him
[Music]
those are the four items he chose
cool
[Music]
we
[Music]
he seemed to work so hard on all this
choreography this kid man
avatar state
man all that off-screen training really
paid off
[Music]
go fight the water
stab the water
[Music]
where's my big tadpole
where the [ __ ] is my big tadpole
they thought that would be too goofy oh
really yeah
really it was about the friendship of
the three of them
with each other look it's better than
dragon ball evolution aung and eero
[Music]
now you bow you bow
i love the fire nation people
what
i guess this is the end of the journey
[Music]
oh this could have been so powerful too
this moment but they just did not do
martial arts
[Music]
you must stop the avatar from
mastering earth and fire you must give
us the time to get to that day
it's three years
no problem this unspeakably important
task i'm putting in your hands
oh
too bad we're never gonna get hurt i do
that
damn
but also i'm glad because i feel like
they would have ruined her
this explains a lot
that
explains
so much for me we did it
we did it
oh my god
kathleen kennedy produced this you
ruined the last jedi
star wars and now this you just ruined
everything they could have knocked out
like half a season in their post-credits
scenes it's so weird because at the
beginning it's like it you don't
understand that they are going like
season by season you just assume it's
all going to be covered in this one
movie because they move so fast what are
they gonna do about bossing saying when
we didn't get jet
this is the last movie
the last airbender indeed there's no
there's no other one moving after this
one
i'm excited for the netflix show i was
gonna say is it live action yeah
fast what i do
oh there's just so much potential for
this to be so cool you know like it's
always like i said if they wanted to do
like a live-action naruto show i think
it'd be so cool if it's well done but
boy it got worse as it was going along
no yeah just kevin is is slowly
i'll talk about it let me just i don't
think there's a post if there is we're
not watching it all right
i can't tell them
all right guys listen
it's better than dragon ball evolution
so it gives a high recommendation
you did not sit through dragon ball
evolution i should not and
i've never seen any of dragon ball so
it it doesn't matter it is that is that
was a really boring ass
yeah that was like wow this is atrocious
and and
this was at least like
it looked good at times and
had a kid who could do some good stick
fighting
had a really good form so obsessed with
that why
just because i know what it's like to be
a little kid in martial arts and i'm
watching him like he's actually really
good at he's better than most actors who
they train to be martial artists in
movies and like he was believable in the
in the fighting and so i was
appreciative of that it's hard to find
like a little kid who can has he he had
the surface cadence of aang you know
that hey
i'm what's the word i'm looking for
not affable kind of laughable
i didn't even think that it was
laughable they're all so boring
i know they're boring everyone's boring
in this room
they're terribly boring
like eggs sometimes ang
aong in here has no personality there's
no doubt
at least
while sometimes he could be like kind of
stoic
it's because you're you know his journey
he's learning to be who he is after
being frozen for a hundred years here
i'm just like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this one
well thanks thanks i remember aang being
like kind of funny and uh yeah he was
like he had a really big crush on cora
katara and
and uh he felt like a
an actual like little kid
and
and um there was a depth to him because
he was really pained by the the
the guilt he felt over abandoning yeah
everyone like everything in here but
but it's actually you know
yeah a character thing in
the show it's actually part of the chat
and this
show this movie
that's
because i i did start thinking like i
think they're just skipping character
beats and moving the plot and the second
they got to um
uh where'd they get to the southern
water tribe the second they got to the
southern water and tribe and
and and then this is the very second the
voice over this pointless point this
voiceover that's clearly there just to
speed things along
uh went uh and my brother fell and i got
along really well with the princess i'm
like okay i guess
there's just
that is it they just skip fast character
beats and just hop straight to like
we've moved this train going man
we got a lot of plot to cover here we're
trying to chat we don't we didn't want
to cut anything out
they've traveled with him for how long
on
oppa
and didn't tell him that he'd been in
the thing for a hundred they didn't
decipher that while talking to him
during their journey
well the show he he learns that when
he's on the boat in the first two
episodes he's like dealing he's having
the crisis there and the epiphany oppa
is a character
momo is a character
here they're just like pointless animals
well there's i mean like
the thing is we could spend all day
comparing this to the show
when i think anyone who's watching she
already knows how [ __ ] atrocious of a
movie this is there are moments it's
just a bad movie it's like a it's a bad
movie if you watch our reactions to
avatar the last serving of the show
i have a lot of criticisms with yeah the
show it goes up and down yeah it goes up
and down for me but
but there's a lot of like
fantastic episodes this ends on a strong
note yeah it's way
even the worst episodes that i did like
i would watch a hundred times oh yeah
this definitely definitely like at the
end of the day we should have watched
this first
you know what this is so bad
but i i feel like if even if i didn't
watch the show i would put this on and
be bored out of my freaking mind there's
nothing to keep me interested in the
characters i don't care about any of the
relationships
it it jumps around so much and the
acting is almost
i don't want to say cartoony because i
feel like what we got on the show is
better than what we got here like it
would have had more personality if it
was cartoony yeah it's just flat it's
it's really flat
weird i don't like it at all
i mean no chemistry between any of the
actors
which is which is so weird to me because
i'm like you guys had a show to pull
from like the actors and m night
shyamalan directing his actors there's a
show to pull from
for the characters and and i'm like if
you're
at least make it up with good acting and
i'm like how can you not even do that it
was so like saka was
they butchered to me the one that's
really butchered is saka really i think
zuko's destroyed here i at least got
what dev patel was going for he was
going to go for that like oh i'm in pain
and i'm i'm angst but no there's no
there's no threat no build up with his
relationship with his uncle and how
important that is you get but they don't
really understand how
tension filled the relationship with
this father because you have that same
with this father being like don't heart
my child but the soccer okay oh yeah the
[ __ ] the father is actually no yeah i
would i would actually say i forget the
father's name firelord um
he he's probably the most butchered
because he's he's destroyed he was like
intense and scary and and the way they
built him up and then when he had scenes
you were just like this guy has no soul
like he is just the worst he's a big
baddie in the show you know he's the one
who hangs the big showdown with in the
end
and here he's just like some
like he's weak he seems weak
um he just he seems like a dude who's in
a royalty position but is ultimately
weak
and uh
but with soccer what really upset me is
like he's not funny
a big part of saka is you know
he's got the boomerang it's so funny
with boomerang well he's a good
strategist he's a navigator and and he's
what makes him really likable is he's
not one of the benders but you see how
how necessary he is and how funny he is
um and in here this guy's like just
weirdly just wide-eyed than serious the
whole time like what why couldn't you
just make him funny just make him funny
what sorry about that just try to make
him a little funny
and they didn't feel like brother and
sister katara i mean they're all ruined
they're all when you compare them to
this [ __ ] they're all they're all ruined
they're all ruined
and um i'm glad that i was able to
i'm glad that we waited a little bit
after watching avatar because like we
like korra the second season's a little
weak but uh
but the the but the the
if we had to watch this right after
avatar i think this would have been just
a nightmare etcetera i think
yeah but this at least allowed us some
space to like objectively watch it
without um
without it being like
because yeah in the first 10 minutes i
was going oh [ __ ] i'm worried though i'm
gonna like just i was a little a little
nervous then like this isn't actually as
terrible as i thought everyone said
usually it was pretty and yeah you're
like getting into the world but as it
goes off it has a bit of that wonder to
it and then and they're just getting
adjusted and then it just it literally
just
slowly
yet the movies is doing so much but it
is slowly descending into just the worst
mess where by the time i'm like why are
we here at the southern water tribe and
how did like it doesn't feel like we
built up to this this battle at all and
and you're you're you're they just skip
a lot of scenes start and just like they
cut away from them
they just like cut away from them when
they start or they narrate the rest of
this
there's no real beginning middle and end
to things it's just like [ __ ] happens
that's that's the definition of this
movie is stuff happens and then we get
here because then you think about all
you've covered from aang waking up to
getting kidnapped to escaping to then
freeing phil earthbending villages like
what the hell is going on
spanning that getting captured again um
zuko and then like they shoved so much
in and it it just doesn't flow the
blue spirit they shoved that in and that
goes for a while in the show because you
i mean you know it doesn't go but like
it's built up here it's just like oh you
know they know who it is immediately
it's just well it's a co it's a conflict
where you're like is zuko gonna be good
or bad you know is is this izuko doing
this because he's like zuko was someone
who like
i
would go back and forth between liking
and just absolutely hating and
yeah and then by the third season i
remember i called them
so yeah i mean but you know what
actually
i'm really mad that they butchered that
ending fight because in the first season
it is
like this on the podcast okay
just wait for it to turn off
sorry
sweet wit boy i'm tired and tired
[ __ ] hungry
i thought
bolt for you thanks
gotta be over the knee so too
man
why's it not turning off
because it just turned on
i don't know why it just turned on
because it's boiling here
it's the room
jesus christ okay the lack of air here
the carpet that blows heat
can't wait to move what do you think i'm
always like dirty to see you
always tell you
all right so go take it from like if you
were set by the fight
yeah so i'm
really upset the more i think about it
how that fight went at the end because
in the finale of the first season that
is so visually stunning i remember
not really being into the show up until
the last few episodes and that was what
i was like super into because i thought
visually was that season one i think it
was
okay because oh yeah
season two is when it ends with
with zuko patricia
zuko betraying uh katara yeah yeah yeah
so since at the season one i remember
that's when it really gripped me because
i was like oh they're doing a real
combination of the spirit world and this
visually it was just so beautiful and
and that was the one moment i remember
being
okay i really do like this show and they
[ __ ] just ruined a hair and you don't
get any of that beautiful visual
spirit world mending with egg and or ogg
or whatever you want to call it here
the more you think about it
come here come here baby
come here
tomorrow we hated this
furiosa very mad at it
very bad
angry
anyway
yeah movie's terrible everyone's like
you can literally sum it up with the
action is mediocre
and um
it's it's rush they try jam packing too
much and every character is flat and
then if you compare the characters to
the show that's even worse
like
like i like i'm not even saying you need
to do the show it's just do something
interesting if you're going to change
but they don't
it's so bizarre because they don't
change the characters they just go what
are some traits they have let's just
remove all them and just give them this
one and just move with that
like iro is
was awesome in the show man
and here
here i thought they might do something
interesting with him like he you know
ira is like like a like your chubby
uncle who appears lazy at first but oh
no he's actually a skilled dude and this
guy looks like remember that they're
kind of yoga yeah
yeah yeah that's like a big deal when he
got all buffed because they're like oh
[ __ ] i was in shape
um
but
here he this dude seems like the kind of
like yoga teacher who would bang the
students
you know like that
the hot daddy like oh i got daddy and
she got him
and he calls him uncle but but you never
get the sense of
the uncle and the dad having like
there's a tension between them as
brothers you know there's so much
missing variables here
what's wrong
is awake i'm good we're just talking
come here buddy watch it awake and um
and uh
i don't know it's just so easy like
literally it's just it's and it's just
boring too it's a boring movie it's it's
really boring and that's the worst thing
you can do like there's no life in this
movie at least
i can please give us comedy i can always
settle for it's bad but it's so fun like
i could at least settle for that but
when once you reach
boring territory then i'm like ah dammit
movie why'd you have to go boring on me
because yeah that's it's not even
because it it doesn't
it
it doesn't
quite it just fall it reads flat instead
of
super cheesy you know and if you just
went like super cheesy that would have
been enough
just just at least commit to being over
the top cheesy
but didn't do that look at him he just
laid there i know i'm so happy that's
quiet he's just like they didn't come in
here like what's he doing in here right
now he just that's all that's cause i i
used a whole bottle of quiet moment
spray
all over this house
i've had a phantom sh everywhere
look at him i got there the ac system
look how tired he is he is so sleepy
he's so tired
all right oh let's see we don't need to
give you any pills
we just need to spray that [ __ ]
anyway
i feel like we can go scene by scene and
talk about how this was butchered
especially compared to the show but
it's really easy to sum it up this is
not a good movie and everything
except some of the technical stuff like
some of the visual effects some of the
music is good and uh yeah that's fine
but none of that ever compensates for
the actual scenes there's no it's void
of emotion the actual story's missing
from here it's just
yeah and and i wonder
uh
what makes me so curious is if you've
never seen avatar
like what is the what is this movie
to you would you watch this i i
i can't imagine
i feel like people might be a little
confused at certain moments of just
keeping up with a bunch of bored they're
bored like like okay i'm just you're
titling things and saying where you are
but i don't know what this is like i
don't know what's happening really you
know like even for me i'm like wait
what's the plot of this movie is i had
to remind myself of the show of oh yeah
he needs to like become gather learn the
at the element it's just so it's so
disjointed and so not focused it is all
over the place and i don't want to be
wrong in this but i think i'm right in
the first season the whole reason why
the fire nation wanted to get rid of the
moon spirit was because their powers
were weakened during the moons during
that full moon i thought i thought
that's the whole reason that's not even
mentioned here it's just like we don't
like the moon spirit stab the fish well
they they've it's because the water
benders are stronger when they have the
moon for the moon so they were like
let's eliminate the moon
yeah
but the water benders lose all their
powers when the moon and here
when it was played up in the show i
thought that
the fire nation specifically lost they
were not able to use their power during
certain moments or is that social's
comment i don't remember that's susan's
comment that's the comment i thought
they're supposed to be more powerful
during the comic
but the comet's not into play here at
all
i know
[Laughter]
it's sweater
yeah why did that fall on me
i don't know
it's missing
development clearly
i don't know how many times when i say
that it's just not good
i ca i guess it's it's funny we see
dragon ball is one of those movies where
you're like
you clearly didn't even watch the show
like that's so it's so obvious you
didn't watch the show
and what's odd to me is like
i feel like you guys watch the show
because this is all from the show
so
and there are looks that are directly
pulling from the show
and i just don't understand how no one
stepped in to be like how do you not
do you realize what you're skipping over
here like do you know what this is to me
and you said it perfectly
i told you about that client i would
work with who
would
love to listen to me read descriptions
of movies from wikipedia yeah and i
would just read the plot description
that's what this entire movie is it's
like if you
just took out all the personality and
character and just
plot description from wikipedia if you
had someone reading
and you're in your mind visualizing
what's happening it would be this
that's what this movie is a big part of
of the show is
with aang is wondering is him struggling
to develop all his abilities especially
with fire
and
and it's and it's like is he gonna be
ready in time for when the moment comes
you know when he really has to when he
has to fight the fire lord
and
here it's like he's got a little bit of
like uh it's like he's got the water
down but he's like i'm a little scared
like that's what it is he's like oh my
god i'm a little trouble i got a little
slight bit of trauma here this is i
don't want to deal with it but for the
most part he's got like a great handle
on everything so it never feels like
anything's at stake there's like zero
stakes in this fight a certain point he
has this whole weight of
him being the only one who could save
the world on him and you feel that in
the show in here it's just blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah yeah
what is happening yeah this is so this
is so not focused and and there's and
the bottom line is you
you can't tell a season's worth the
television in two hours there's not even
two hours
and you can't tell season with
television two hours you can't tell
you can't tell us he's worth the
television three hours like you should
have told this much story you just
shouldn't have done this much plain and
simple you shouldn't have done all this
you know you just can't introduce a
bunch of
plots without it's like you got to focus
on something something has to be the
focus and and bottom line is like you
just
it usually doesn't work to develop a
show into a movie
nine times out of ten
especially with like things like that
are so rich and lower yeah and
everything because then you feel like
the need to i gotta include some of this
like earth betting was so unimportant to
this story
you could have removed it it was so
unnecessary
that whole scene was yeah the whole
scene wasn't necessary
so yeah i don't know how to get the
point i guess and there are moments
where the fire people are literally just
standing in the back waiting their turn
to fight
i'll peel lost okay oh yeah fire nation
doesn't seem like a threat at all who's
next oh my turn to go up there i'm like
what is happening it's so bad all right
guys i want to talk about this
i'm so blind follow some picture up for
all the other things that we like to
cover but thanks for being here at least
we finally watch this [ __ ] bye
[Music]